what else is going on what have I been
thinking about oh they have this trail
of um not a trail they have a tribe I
guess you would say maybe of Hondurans
allegedly coming towards the US border I
was thinking about this a lot because
this is you know this is like a new
thing that you know the media really
blasts out and uses is like a scare
tactic and a thing you know but it's
also a real thing that there are real
people who are experiencing some sort of
trauma or something in their country and
they have left their country in our you
know caravanning towards the US and it
makes me think a lot about you know a
lot about illegal aliens or you know you
know immigrants people come to the u.s.
you know when I checked out my father
came here legally from Nicaragua in 1922
I believe people have come legally and
illegally over the years we know that I
I love the idea of having a very legal
system for people to get into the
country I love this I thought about this
could be a neat idea that look I'm all
about strengthening up the borders
making so you know who's coming in it's
just not safe to not know who is around
you know it's like a roll call I wish
every year we did a roll call where we
just where everybody had to go next door
there exact next neighbor and find out
who in the [__] they were and do a book
report on their neighbor because we
don't know it you can't keep you can't
run a good company if you don't know the
inventory you can't do it and here's
what I thought though I thought this is
a lot of the issues are are we
mistreating people are people being
mistreated you know there's so many
great people in America in the world I
was thinking we should the part of the
program
for having elite people who are not
already legal citizens of the US
part of the program could be that there
is a you can sign up to help someone you
can sign up to foster a family too
okay I can help to Honduran people can
stay at my place for this much time you
know they can stay here for this much
time I can help for this you know I they
can stay and work with me doing I feel
like there would be a really great
program of people that want to help and
then people that need help because
that's really what you're dealing with
but I think that then you would have an
exact account of what's going on you'd
have somebody to help somebody get
acclimated into what it's like to be in
America or what it's like to live in a
new place
and then you solve a lot of that problem
then you because otherwise we don't know
what it's like for people living right
on the border you know and suddenly
people are in their yards and running
and they're starving and scared or
thirsty we we don't know what that's
like if we're not right there
you know I just feel like we could have
a smarter program overall to help people
come in what do I know
you know what am I know I'm just
thinking out loud good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one